>> Sean: TODAY FORMER SPEAKER
OF THE HOUSE NEWT GINGRICH HAD
HARSH WORDS FOR THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION.
>> THE FACT IS ROD ROSENSTEIN
HAS NOT DONE HIS JOB.
HE HAS NOT SUPERVISED MUELLER.
THIS WHOLE THING IS AN
ABSURDITY.
WE NOW HAVE PAUL MANAFORT AND
HIS WIFE IN THEIR PAJAMAS AT
3:00 IN THE MORNING HAVING THE
FBI BREAK DOWN THE DOOR.
WE'VE HAD LAST WEEK, COHEN THE
LAWYER HAD THE DOOR AND TAKEN
OFF THE HINGES.
WE ARE SUPPOSED TO HAVE THE RULE
OF LAW.
IT AIN'T THE RULE OF LAW WHEN
THEY KICK IN YOUR DOOR AT 3:00
IN THE MORNING AND YOU ARE FACED
WITH ARMED MEN.
YOU HAVE NO REASON TO BE TOLD
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE A KIND OF
TREATMENT.
THAT IS STALLING.
THAT IS THE GESTAPO.
SHOULDN'T BE THE AMERICAN FBI.
>> Sean: WE CONTINUE WITH JOE
DiGENOVA AND PROFESSOR ALAN
DERSHOWITZ.
THESE TACTICS ARE NOT AMERICAN.
THAT'S THE POINT.
THIS IS WHAT WE EXPECT IN
VENEZUELA.
THIS IS NOT THE UNITED STATES OR
ANYTHING.
SO MY QUESTION TO YOU, WHAT IT
SO MY QUESTION TO YOU, WHAT IT D
SO MY QUESTION TO YOU, WHAT IT E
SO MY QUESTION TO YOU, WHAT IT S
THE PRESIDENT NOW DO?
I DON'T THINK HE CAN IN GOOD
FAITH EVER TALK TO ROBERT
MUELLER ANYMORE.
>> NOBODY SHOULD EVER TALK TO A
PROSECUTOR UNLESS THEY HAVE
ABSOLUTELY NO ALTERNATIVE.
NO PROSECUTOR IS TRYING TO HELP
A PERSON WHO IS A SUBJECT OF AN
INVESTIGATION.
JUST ASK MARTHA STEWART WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN YOU TALK TO
PROSECUTORS.
>> Sean: THAT WAS HORRIBLE.
IT WASN'T THAT LYING TO THE FBI?
NOT THE UNDERLYING CRIME.
>> THAT'S OF COURSE WHY THEY
WANT HIM TO COME AND TESTIFY.
YOU CAN BE CHARGED WITH PERJURY
FOR TELLING THE TRUTH.
IF SOMEBODY ELSE GIVES A
CONTRARY STORY AND PROSECUTORS
DO BELIEVE THE OTHER PERSON.
YOU CAN END UP IN A PERJURY TRAP
FOR TELLING THE TRUTH.
>> Sean: UNBELIEVABLE TIMES.
I REMEMBER DURING THE CLINTON
IMPEACHMENT, PEOPLE LIKE
PROFESSOR DERSHOWITZ, JOE, WERE
SAYING WHERE'S THE SENSE OF
PROPORTIONALITY?
WHERE IS THE PROSECUTORIAL
DISCRETION IN A LOT OF THESE
THINGS?
I WORRY FOR THE COUNTRY BECAUSE
THE PRESIDENT NO LONGER CAN
TRUST MUELLER.
WHAT IS HIS LEGAL TEAM TO DO
HERE BECAUSE I WOULD ARGUE
THEY'VE GOT TO GO ON OFFENSE AND
THEY'VE GOT TO MAKE THEIR CASE.
THEY'VE GOT TO UNDERSTAND IT
SEEMS LIKE THERE IS NO TOPIC
THAT'S OFF THE TABLE HERE.
>> AS A RESULT OF THE TACTICS
AUTHORIZED BY MUELLER AND
INSTIGATED BY MUELLER IN
NEW YORK WITH THE RAID OF THE
COHEN OFFICE, AND AS A RESULT IN
THE MANNER IN WHICH THEY RAIDED
PAUL MANAFORT, IT'S CLEAR THAT
MUELLER IS ACTING IN BAD FAITH,
AND HE HAS SURROUNDED HIMSELF
WITH LITERALLY A BUNCH OF LEGAL
TERRORISTS AND THEY ARE
CONDUCTING A GRAND JURY.
NOT INTERESTED IN GETTING BACK
FROM THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES THROUGH AN
INTERVIEW.
THEY ARE TRYING        TRYING T
THEY ARE TRYING        TRYING TR
THEY ARE TRYING        TRYING TP
THEY ARE TRYING        TRYING TH
THEY ARE TRYING        TRYING TM
THEY ARE TRYING        TRYING TI
THEY ARE TRYING        TRYING TT
THEY ARE TRYING        TRYING TO
A PERJURY TRAP OR TRYING TO GET
INFORMATION TO CENTER ROSENSTEIN
TO TRANSFER TO THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES.
IMPROPER METHODS FOR SEEKING, TO
QUESTION THE PRESIDENT.
THE PRESIDENT SHOULD REFUSE TO
COOPERATE.
NO DOCUMENTS, NO TESTIMONY.
IF NECESSARY, --
>> I DON'T THINK HE SHOULD TAKE
THE FIFTH.
IF HE TAKES THE FIFTH, THEY CAN
GIVE HIM IMMUNITY AND THEY CAN
COMPEL HIM TO TESTIFY.
AND THE EVIDENCE CAN BE USED
AGAINST HIM IN THE IMPEACHMENT
PROCEEDING.
I THINK IT'S A MISTAKE.
HE CAN TAKE THE SIXTH.
LET ME EXPLAIN.
WHAT HE SAYS IS I WOULD LOVE TO
TESTIFY.
I HAVE NOTHING TO HIDE, BUT MY
LAWYERS HAVE TOLD ME THAT UNDER
NO CIRCUMSTANCES WILL THEY ALLOW
ME TO TESTIFY.
I DON'T WANT TO LOSE MY LAWYERS.
I HAVE A RIGHT TO BE REPRESENTED
BY COUNSEL, AND I HAVE TO LISTEN
TO MY LAWYERS.
>> Sean: WHAT ABOUT, JOE, I
LAID OUT, LOOK AT THE TEAM
MUELLER HAS PUT TOGETHER.
WHY WOULD ANYBODY WHO IS
SUPPOSED TO BE FAIR, BALANCED,
AND OBJECTIVE THE EVER HIGHER
ANDREW WEISSMANN.
ONE OF THE MOST ATROCIOUS
RECORDS OF ANY LAWYER I'VE EVER
READ ABOUT.
FRANKLY, EVEN MUELLER GOING BACK
TO BOSTON AND THE ANTHRAX CASE.
THESE ARE NOT SMALL CASES.
>> LET ME SAY I AGREE WITH
EVERYTHING ALAN SAID.
I TAKE A DIFFERENT VIEW OF WHY
THE PRESIDENT SHOULD TAKE ALL
LEGAL STEPS NECESSARY TO AVOID
TESTIFYING.
BY THE WAY, IF MUELLER ATTEMPTED
TO IMMUNIZE HIM, I HAPPEN TO
BELIEVE THERE ARE LEGAL
ARGUMENTS THAT WOULD MAKE THE
PRESIDENT NOT HAVE TO COMPLY
WITH IN ORDER TO MAKE HIM
TESTIFY BEFORE A GRAND JURY.
LET'S PUT THAT ASIDE.
MUELLER IS NOW, HAS NO
LEGITIMACY.
THE TACTICS THEY HAVE CHOSEN TO
USE AGAINST A PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, AGAINST WHOM
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE OF A CRIME
AND NEVER HAS BEEN FROM THE
BEGINNING, THE USE OF THOSE
TECHNIQUES HAS DELEGITIMIZED
THIS INVESTIGATION.
HERE'S THE OTHER THING THAT'S
GOING ON.
ROBERT MUELLER AND ROD
ROSENSTEIN AND CHRISTOPHER WRAY
ARE DOING MORTAL DAMAGE TO THE
INSTITUTIONS THEY REPRESENT.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE KNOW WHAT'S
GOING ON.
THEY ARE WATCHING THIS, AND THEY
ARE NOT HAPPY.
AND I MUST TELL YOU ROBERT
MUELLER, I USED TO THINK WAS A
DECENT GUY AND A GUY WHO HAD A
GREAT CAREER.
HE IS DESTROYING HIS REPUTATION
THROUGH THE THUGGISH TACTICS
WHICH HE HAS AUTHORIZED AND
THROUGH THE PEOPLE HE HAS
SURROUNDED HIMSELF WITH.
>> LET ME REMIND YOU WHERE THIS
BEGAN.
LET'S GO BACK IN TIME.
THE CLINTONS WERE BEING
INVESTIGATED FOR WHITEWATER.
WHAT HE DID END UP WITH?
ENDED UP WITH A PERJURY CHARGE
FOR NOT DISCLOSING AN ALLEGED
RELATIONSHIP WITH A WOMAN THAT
HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
ALLEGED UNDERLYING CRIME.
WE ALLOWED THAT TO HAPPEN.
SOME OF THE SAME PEOPLE
COMPLAINING TODAY WERE PUSHING
THAT KIND OF THING.
INCLUDING SOME OF THE SENATORS
AND CONGRESSMEN.
IN.
>> I AM JUST SAYING THAT I AGREE
WITH ALAN.
I THINK YOU SHOULDN'T REPEAT A
MISTAKE.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU WHAT BOB
MUELLER IS DOING AND HAS DONE IS
DESTROYING THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
FOR JEFF SESSIONS TO SIT THERE
LIKE A BUMP ON A LOG AND DO
NOTHING ABOUT IT IS DISGRACEFUL.
>> Sean: I THINK WE ALL AGREE
ON THAT.
>> I TAKE IT ONE STEP FURTHER.
I THINK JEFF SESSIONS ENGAGED IN
WRONGFUL CONDUCT BY NOT TELLING
THE PRESIDENT BEFORE HE WAS
APPOINTED.
>> NEVER WOULD HAVE APPOINTED
HIM.
THE PRESIDENT DOESN'T WANT A
PART-TIME ATTORNEY GENERAL.
>> SHOULD HAVE APPOINTED JOE